las muertes de decenas de civiles en la
ciudad de muchas afueras de kiev
atribuidas al ejército ruso han
conmocionado a todos los países de la
unión europea por ello como respuesta a
varios países han anunciado la expulsión
de diplomáticos rusos de sus países una
muestra clara del deterioro de la
relación entre europa y rusia por su
parte letonia y lituania fueron los
primeros en anunciar esta expulsión este
ultimo lituania expulsado al embajador
ruso de su capital de vilnius y también
ha hecho regresar a su embajador que se
encontraba en moscú letonia por su parte
también ha anunciado una reducción de
las relaciones diplomáticas con rusia
alemania también ha anunciado una
expulsión de 40 diplomáticos y francia
también de otros 35 éstos se unen ya
también a la expulsión de otros países
como bélgica y países bajos anunciadas
la semana pasada por supuesto espionaje
lo cierto es que las informaciones
provenientes de bucha han conmocionado
enormemente a todo occidente de hecho la
unión europea reforzando un quinto
paquete de sanciones en las que no se
descarta un posible embargo del petróleo
y también del carbón ruso aún así es una
cuestión muy divisivo entre las
capitales europeas y además se ha
anunciado que el jefe de la diplomacia
europea zew se aburre de la presenta la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen
viajarán a finales de esta semana a kiev
para reunirse con el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr sellers